uh i know that many albertans myself
foremost have been frustrated with uh
the ongoing blockade the interruption of
other people's lives the violation of
other people's rights the safety hazard
that this represents uh and will be very
distressed to learn about this
small group that apparently uh have had
violent intent
uh
that were
involved and have been identified and
now detained
this underscores the severity of what
has been happening and to those who have
been impatient about enforcement i ask
them to understand that um this
investigation has been ongoing uh for
the past over the past week
and the rcmp obviously did not want to
escalate the situation that could
provoke
potential violence
until they had a tactical plan in place
at the appropriate time to take
enforcement action and to seize these
weapons as they've done early this
morning
and so now that uh the rcmp has
successfully resolved uh this potential
threat
they will proceed i'm informed uh with
enforcement against
others who are involved in the blockade
at and around coots
the government of alberta has
successfully procured all of the
necessary heavy equipment and service uh
to uh
operate that equipment to assist the
police in removing
commercial vehicles and other vehicles
that may be blocking our highways
throughout all of this it's important to
underscore that traffic across the
alberta montana border has operated
largely unimpeded because we have six
ports of entry uh between alberta and
montana five of which have continued to
operate uh according to either normal or
in fact extended hours
i'd like to thank the canada border
services agency and the
united states customs and border
protection agency for their diligent
cooperation uh in extending hours and
providing those services
and so i my message to those who are
still involved in the blockade at coots
is that you know you have not closed the
border all you've done is to
inconvenience thousands and thousands of
hard-working truckers who have been
trying to do their job to make a living
just forcing them to drive longer
distances for no point
you've sent your message
we encourage people uh to continue to
express their views in a lawful and
peaceful way
but the ongoing blockade of our borders
and our highways at coots will no longer
be tolerated and now that this uh
very delicate security challenge has
been resolved successfully by the police
as i say broader enforcement measures
will commence um and of course the
government of alberta will be there to
support that every step of the way